Rusia y Estados Unidos están negociando
un intercambio de presos que podría
devolver la libertad a algunos
norteamericanos reclusos en Rusia Como
por ejemplo la jugadora de baloncesto
femenino Brittany que fue detenida aquí
en Rusia este mismo año pero el precio
que hay que pagar es bastante alto
porque
Moscú exige entre otras cosas la entrega
de El conocido Traficante de armas rusos
Víctor bota apodado el mercader de la
muerte si Brittany Green es una estrella
del baloncesto femenino Víctor Boat es
un patrocinador de la guerra que ha
vendido armas a los talibán al qaeda y
también a Los Rebeldes de uganda ya
cuando fue condenado en el año 2011 dijo
que aquello no iba a acabar así y 11
años después puede llegar su oportunidad
de obtener la libertad gracias a una
jugadora de baloncesto que cometió el
enorme crimen de llevar un poco de
marihuana consigo en Rusia